[Musique]
beaucoup d'inquiétudes sur l'état de
santé de jean lassalle le député udf
vient d'entamer sa sixième semaine de
grève de la faim à l'assemblée nationale
et il est toujours aussi déterminé jean
lassalle protestent contre le risque de
délocalisation d'une usine de sa
circonscription 150 emplois sont en jeu
sandrine rigaud et georges milan bois
comme tous les matins jean lassalle se
prépare pour sa visite médicale des
gestes quotidiens qui l'épuisent tous
les jours un peu plus depuis le début de
sa grève de la faim il passe ses nuits
dans son bureau à l'assemblée pour
limiter les déplacements
son état devient critique au bout de 37
jours il a déjà perdu 21 kg et ce matin
son médecin lui a demandé de rester
couché
g8 et demi et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quart le député udf ne veut pas déserter
la salle des quatre colonnes qui est
devenu son qg autour de lui les
journalistes sont plus nombreux plus
inquiète aussi et certains députés
commencent à craindre le pire
je suis très inquiète pour lui
aujourd'hui et imaginez-vous que si cet
homme
députée française en responsabilité qui
meurent à l'assemblée nationale
et vous ce que cela veut dire au niveau
de la désespérance
du politique nicolas sarkozy s'occupe
désormais personnellement du dossier
une démarche qui rassure y compris
certains députés socialistes si sarkozy
est sur le dossier il va tout faire pour
le développer
il va tout faire pour le débloquer il y
a quelques jours le ministre de
l'intérieur a envoyé une lettre aux
dirigeants japonais de toya lé
l'entreprise qui risquent de délocaliser
pour l'instant aucune réponse alors jean
lassalle continue sont jeunes mais
certains organes vitaux pourraient être
touchées dès la semaine prochaine
[Musique]